it was simply a webinar
it's a panel discussion startup career
strategy highs and lows
and uh it's hosted today by krishna
kumar
the president ceo and founder of simply
learn
our guests today are ashish gupta of
helium advisors and dr ram
ram gupta of aryanka networks
and um before we get started i just want
to go over with you
a couple of tips on how to interact with
us during the webinar
the control buttons include the chat
button which is that word bubble
please select all panelists and you'll
get the questions and accumul
and answer those um for the q a
at the end of the webinar use the
question mark button
or the three dots and you'll be able to
get to um the q a panel
um we will collect all the questions
and answer those at the q a session uh
toward the end of the webinar
with that i would like to
introduce krishna
so thanks stuart and welcome everyone
to this webinar i'm really excited to
host this webinar on a topic that
i think about all the time but let me
first introduce
two of my panelists i think both of them
are accomplished
entrepreneur uh i'm sure you have done
some search about who they are
on your own before you decided to spend
your time being part of this webinar but
let me introduce themselves
to everyone once again so i have dr
ashish gupta who is one of my
panelists today on the on this
discussion and ashish has done multiple
things but i will just point out
couple of things that might be very
relevant for the audience and you can
ask questions
to him accordingly so ashish has been
has backed
in the startup world for i don't know
maybe more than
20 years at least and he has been he has
backed multiple companies uh
through his um last uh so many years of
journey
and some of those companies iconic
uh and household names to name a few he
was the early backers of companies like
flipkart
um mick might rave
nakari info is that that runs this
portal cornocary
is also built and sold companies to the
likes of amazon so
understands the startup ecosystem really
very well both in india as well as in us
so welcome ashish to this discussion i
am really excited to ask a lot of
questions from you
and then i have the my next panelist is
ram gupta again ram
is a veteran when it comes to the
business world i think
startup as a world maybe got coined
maybe the last 10 years in india for
sure
but ram has been has been has been
building and scaling companies
and working towards their exit for many
many years before a startup award
world what got introduced to the to the
indian dictionary
and he has been part of multiple
companies that got exited by
being acquired by the likes of ibm
oracle hp he took multiple companies to
public
and today he actively advises a lot of
high growth startup
and one of his companies that became in
uh that got that took uh that got
into limelight and is became a household
name is
postman i'm sure those of you who are
from the b2b world
must have used that company or must be
aware about what postman does
and one thing that is common between
both ashish and ram is that both are on
both
both of them are on simply on board and
i get to interact with them quite often
but today
i will not keep anything related to
simply learning this discussion and
we'll
focus on generic topics and and try to
answer a lot of questions that comes
from
[Music]
audience who are part of the part of
this
webinar so feel free to keep writing
your questions and keep writing it on
the chat window
i'll pick up those questions as and when
i find them relevant
on the topics that i am going to take up
during this
discussion so ashish and i'm again
welcome to the show
the first thing that i want to ask both
of you and before we get started with
the flow of the
webinar is that see startup
is a very positive word in today's
business world for sure and all kinds of
companies are using this word right
so what it what the word says that
startup is something that just got
started
maybe one year old maybe two year old
maybe three year old but
there are companies who are maybe as old
as tenure but they still use this word
startup
so when you uh hear this word call it
there's a startup
doing something uh innovative in some in
some uh technology areas or something
that is futuristic
how what what comes to your mind like
how do you define startup
where do you draw the line between a
startup and an established setup
what's what's your definition of a
startup i should go with you first and
then ram i'll
also like you to answer this that
question um
sure and i'm sure there are many ways of
looking at it
one way that i look at it is a company
that does not have visibility into its
existence past two years
uh in my mind is still a startup
okay so i like for example if i look at
at least
i am based in bangalore so i understand
the bangalore and india ecosystem better
and i don't have much visibility about
the us system
but in india even even companies like
flipkart which are like multi multi
billion dollar companies household names
one of the largest one of the largest
global ecommerce company
when people call them also a startup how
do you look at that
so i think there it is more a discussion
of i guess the
attitude that they believe they want to
bring to bear for example amazon is
known to
regularly tell everybody it is still day
one
in that every day is a new day so
i think from an attitude perspective one
can consider a lot of things as startups
which can be associated with either
innovation
or hustle or uh
paranoia and so and so forth
however i end up looking at it more from
perspective of
if the company has enough visibility
into its
cash flow then for a lot of the other
purposes that we were talking about
today
it stops being a startup uh in my
vocabulary
but from an attitude perspective yes a
fairly large company can also behave
like a startup
good so thanks so ram how do you define
startups
where do you draw the line uh for me
you know startup is
like a child being born and when the
child is born
it needs there's so much potential that
when the child is born
unlimited potential when it starts and
each day this goes by it grows up
you know it's uh three four five years
old
and the infant mortality is sort of what
ashish was mentioning
at about age five uh goes down
dramatically
so from zero to five i think your
companies are truly startup
when they have existential threat of
going out of business
and the primary driving attitude in that
of founders and everybody working there
is is survival his hustle
is doing things on a shoestring budget
and not having the concept of
taking things for granted and there
comes a point in time when the
culture and attitude starts to change in
the company you mentioned flipkart
flipkart has hundreds of vice presidents
and when you have hundreds of vice
presidents you you may want to call
yourself a startup but you're not and
there is a age-old saying
all startups want to become big
companies
and all big companies want to act like
startups
and neither is kind of a circle of life
you want to start a company
and then you're gonna become a large
company and and then you will stop
acting like a startup and the large
company would want to act like a startup
when they can
and just goes down in cycles so for me
is a zero to five year
journey that feels a lot like startup
after that it becomes a good old company
okay so thank you for that so i i have
one observation when it comes to startup
and that observation is that
as long as the the original founder who
started the startup
is still running the show it acts like a
startup do you agree with this statement
or you think uh
this might this might be true in a few
cases but uh not in majority of the
cases
what's has been your objective because
i'm sure collectively you guys have seen
at least 100 plus startup right
my observation has been that like like
even google right
larry is still running was running it
that a page
it wasn't the startup after a while
it changed completely i worked with
people software dave duffield was
running it it was in the start
so just that the original founder is
still there
doesn't quite uh feel like a startup
it's all there's another way to think
about it is when the
company loses his hustle to the
and as a controversial statement but
i'll make it
to the process when the process takes
over innovation
there's a point in time in company when
the process takes over innovation
and that's the point you know now it's
no longer a startup
got it so ashish since we spoke about uh
and you have been part of me from day
one and you know that company
i think is close quarters and they and
the founders were running the company
till recently
until about two years back what has been
what has been your observation
on on the point that you are making that
so i think i'll make a slightly
different
uh nuance of the behavior that a founder
perpetuates in a company and i don't
know if the word startup captures it but
there is definitely a higher degree
of risk taking
in the vast majorities of companies that
continue to be run by the original
founders
now whether i would call that a startup
or not that might be stretching it too
far in my view
but there is definitely a higher degree
of risk taking ability
in companies that continue to get run by
founders and i think that has to do with
the fact that
this risk-taking gene doesn't just go
away
and that can be seen in a lot of
companies across the board
whether it be the current technology
behemoths
um that a lot of a lot of us are seeing
the
as i mentioned google until recently
was being done by larry or by facebook
or amazon
or even oracle interestingly the fact
that larry ellison continues to run the
company
i think a level of risk-taking that
feeds professionally managed companies
is definitely there
i wouldn't go so far as to call them
startups
i completely agree now i'll move up to
the next
point that i wanted to discuss is that
see if you look at
some of these tech hubs like bangalore
bay area and many other tech hubs
there's a lot of fascination in people
to join startups especially the
technology startup right
so you have been part of many such
startups and you have been
interviewing and hiring people advising
ceos and boards that
what kind of talent you should hire so
when you look at candidates who look
forward to joining technology startup
now why the startups are hiring we know
as a management team pretty well right
there's a need there is a growth and you
want to
hire certain kind of people but when you
look at from
those prospective candidates who join
this technology startup
what's their uh what's on top of their
mind like why do they look at joining
startups
they look at joining because they think
that this is the in thing to do
or they look at that as a shortest way
to become rich because a lot of startups
end up becoming a real large company and
giving a lot of
good financial outcome to people who are
part of the journey
or you think that startups have this
notion in the in the in the job market
that startups
provide a culture where you can do a lot
of innovation and you have a lot of
flexibility to make decisions
what are some of the things that you
have seen when from the candidate
perspective not from the employer
perspective when people look at joining
startups
uh do you want me to go first krishna
okay um so uh it changes from
um geography to geography by the way
so i remember a friend who's been at
microsoft for 25 years
moved to the bay area and he was telling
me that now whenever he attends a party
and people ask him what do you do and he
says i work at microsoft and then they
ask him how long and he says 25 years
after that nobody talks to him
so so i think it changes
very seriously depending upon what
geography you are in
um so in some places it is just
cool if you are in hollywood and you are
not got an idea for making a movie
the chances are you are in the wrong
place so
part of it is just the kind of people
who show up in bangalore or in the bay
area
uh they are more inclined to go work
in a startup so some of it is a
self-fulfilling prophecy
in terms of some of the other reasons
that i have seen
a lot of people end up going to startups
because they believe that they
themselves want to become a customer at
some point
um
peer pressure which is seldom a good way
to be
a good reason to be working in a startup
but turns out to be a
frequent reason why people end up
working in startup
for repeat offenders
after they have once worked in a startup
i think it is the adrenaline
it is very hard to forget about the rush
that comes out of
being in a small company it's like uh
small volume allows you to move with
higher velocity and faster so the first
derivative becomes a larger number
even though the absolute impact might be
close to zero uh but that adrenaline
rush that comes out of a lot of change
is the reason i think people continue to
stay in startups
they might not enter them for that
reason for repeat offenders it also
becomes clear that the financial payout
promises don't often deliver
so there i think it changes over to a
dream
yeah so i i have
interesting tv content maybe which is
i think people joining a startup
is like going on and having a child
going ahead and having a child you know
a child
is something you create that didn't
exist before
that you created now and when you
created it you got
immense responsibility you know they
wake up in the night they bother you
you have to feed them and take care of
them you become responsible for
something that didn't take and
if you have that attitude and you join a
startup you do well
and the other on the spectrum is if you
want to go
stay with your parents you should join a
large company because like
your parents will still take care of you
and have a room for you and will feed
you
and clothe you so people come in two
different flavors
that they want to create something and
and like have a child and it gives the
immense joy when the child grows up and
you know goes to college and becomes the
citizen
and the joy is not necessarily financial
it's sometimes
financial sometimes it is it just the
the the joy or feeling you get that you
created something
that didn't exist before and hence you
do that and to at this point
the repeat offenders are more like that
that they get the
adrenaline or the joy of creating
something that didn't exist before
and i actually caution people who are
trying to join a startup because of
the reasons you mentioned krishna which
is status
or peer pressure or fast buck that i'll
make quick money
none of them are good reasons to join a
startup because
you will find yourself disillusioned the
the one reason to join a startup
is are you a creator do you enjoy
creating something
that did not exist before and would you
enjoy that
and if not don't do it it's not a job
people shouldn't join a startup looking
for it if you're looking for just a job
you should go join a big company and
where the company will take care of in
the startup
you are taking care of them
it was very very helpful in fact being
part of this startup for so many years i
think i still got
a lot of new points that i never thought
uh before so that's really helpful
so i'll also like to run as a short poll
at this point of time the steward if you
are
there can you run a a poll on
why do people join startup and see what
the audience is and i think that will be
pretty helpful you can publish this
to people who registered but couldn't
join and before i proceed i wanted to
take some
questions that i saw some of the
participants asking and i found them
pretty insightful so one of them is that
if
i'm a prospective candidate and i have
two options to take a larger
responsibility in a smaller company
or take a smaller responsibility in
larger company how do i go about uh
deciding which one should i get
or what is the generic answer like any
one of you if you want to answer that
if let's say if you have some somebody
in a family young guy wants to take your
advice what what is your
advice to you more sorry yeah
who you want to go first i think any one
of you
want to take it please so my advice
to everybody actually is
by in all cases
go to the bigger role
in a smaller company you don't want to
be a cog in the wheel
you'll get frustrated very quickly you
want to have responsibility and
accountability and start a company and
grow with it
and then you'll have uh you know the the
benefits of a clear
but especially earlier on in your career
when you're in your
late 20s early 30s and even 40s
why would you want to be in the wheel
you might as well do a government job
that's what you want why bother about
going to work
work in a private sector at all if you
wanted
in a government job if you think about
it
unless you're the prime minister or the
president or whatever the country
you always have a very small job there
is
limited responsibility do you really
want to do that
and why would you do that when you can
have a good responsibility job with a
smaller setup
and actually have an opportunity to make
a difference
correct so ram i think before i move to
ashish there is a related question that
someone has asked
based on your earlier definition that
startups are more innovative and larger
companies
process takes over innovation so someone
is asking
that do you mean to say that large
companies cannot be innovative if they
want to do something new
how do they go about doing it like one
thing that i see from outside is that
many times large company wants to do
something really quick they end up
end up buying a startup and then
incorporating that product
how do you come across examples where
large companies they wanted to do
something they wanted to move fast
and they indeed acted like a startup
incubated something i really skilled it
successfully so there's so suddenly a
team within a large company starts
working like a startup
because there's a new product line on a
new business id
because you give that definition
somebody has asked the question on their
definition
that you say that when process takes
over innovation that's where the
difference between a startup and an
established companies krishna i think
it'll be good if you just
call it out for me right okay
sir go ahead no
this question was for you
my perception having worked now for 35
years
it is next to impossible
for large companies to work like startup
they all want to they all talk about it
they give speeches about it
and and the only option they have they
get caught up in this
quagmire of pnl and quarterly reporting
to the wall street and earning per share
and taking you know 50 million out and
invest in a project becomes
almost next impossible so the only path
left for them
is to buy a company and you see that all
the time
and not not only in technology by the
way we see that in
pharmaceutical you see that in other
industries as well
that after a certain size innovation
gets very hard
and inside the confines
and it's only done outside and then you
buy them and cisco used to do it before
but they'll actually aggressively spin
out a company for their own employees
now you could argue that why couldn't
they run a team
and the thought was that once you run a
team within the company
you get caught up with the same thing
you said part of the same hr
same finance same building same same
infrastructures
other people away so they'll they'll
start a new company
new corporation new funding new uh stock
option pool
and the employees and work in a
different place all together and if it
worked out well cisco had the first time
to buy it
that model worked well as well and so i
have
rarely seen a a large company pull out
any technology innovation quickly
mostly it is done by startups
so since i'm moving on to you again a
related
point i see a lot of large companies
like you talked about cisco i think
pretty much any any large
all of them have now this concept of
incubation so
they look they have not identified ideas
which are somewhat related to the
domain that they operate in and every
year they have batches of
startups that they incorporate some of
them they fund also and some of them
they just
give them ideas about how how can they
go
how about creating them i
every six months i spend some time with
the hell with the hope that these
companies will scale
they will eventually become part of
their supply chain so
have you seen this kind of systems
working and if if someone is working
can they if someone is in a large
company is looking for
a startup kind of experience is is that
the team to
go for what has been your experience if
you're aware about that
so this word incubator is
about as badly abused
as the word strategy or any other words
that
that often get bandied about and so i'll
use a couple of specific instances of
of incubators krishna and tell me that
it helps address
what you had in mind
krishna do you want me to try it yeah
while we get ashes it will go so
i think these incubators like saying
are multitudes of things for multitudes
of people
and in large companies when they do the
incubators
i think is just the way for them
[Music]
okay then i'll then i'll continue
further which is
so so the large companies basically have
incubators
as a reason for them to look at
potential acquisition
and it's a very good strategy for them
they invest the money some companies
show up
in the incubator if you like it they
have the first size
first opportunity to buy it okay so
ashish i think that
took your question for some time i think
you wanted to share some
uh maybe something good to hear
which is that an elephant is designed
for a certain landscape
a mouse is designed for a different
landscape a horse is designed for a
different landscape and if an elephant
tries to shove itself down a small rat
hole
it gets stuck and
they each have their advantages and
respecting those
strengths always complemented by
weaknesses slash limitations however you
want to see it
is is important and you'll notice by the
way
that every company periodically in that
cycle of life point that ram was making
about
large companies wanting to behave like
startups you'll notice that
during good times every company goes
about
with an incubation innovation program
then an economic downturn comes
they kill everything but their core
business because the cfo stands up and
says what the hell are you doing
i only get rewarded by my p l and they
cut everything extraneous including all
incubators
all venture funding nothing they go back
to basics and then good times come back
and somebody says it is strategic for us
to have
an incubator so you will end up with
that same
thing again which is mostly a boon
toggle for
uh two people okay so that's interesting
too
and what we see is that uh
most people don't think that startups
are a good way to get rich quick
but the the adrenaline rush of the
culture
the ability to be their own boss
or to turn their ideas into
reality uh are all attracted good
so that's really good to know that that
ram i think both of you passed this
message that
if you're really looking at becoming
rich quicker then joining startup is not
a good idea it looks like the
majority of the audience already
understand that so that's really good to
know
so now we'll proceed further and the
next thing that i wanted to talk about
is that
see startup is all good you get a lot of
good satisfaction of creating something
um
you could you get to feel the real
business more closely
and you can get the experience the
satisfaction of creating something doing
something
but how it is really to work for a
startup like
there are a lot of uh talks around that
if you work in a startup you hardly have
your personal life
it's like working 16 hours a day all day
in a week
you get you get burned burned out and
[Music]
it's it's very erratic side so there is
no there is no pattern to it so at some
point in time get confused that whether
we are going in the right direction or
you are not going the right direction
there is competition there are big
companies there are funded
competitors all of them nets all of them
give lot of stress
so is it a right really right place for
someone to go and work for
so when how do they decide whether i
should uh go and work for startups or
or or let me just rephrase this question
if i am a prospective candidate how do i
do my own self
assessment whether this is the right
place for me to go or not
like we talked about general answer that
if you really want to do something
meaningful go and work for a startup
you get a lot of space you get lot of
ability to do something that you always
wanted to do and you can really make an
impact but how do
i decide whether i am cut cut out for
that or not whether i am ready for
long long hours or not or whether long
hour is a
is more a perception or reality what has
been your experience i will start with
you first
okay so i'll go back to my having a
child analogy
uh when you ask yourself are you
prepared to have a child before you have
a child
because once the child is born there's
no going back there are gonna be long
hours
they're gonna wake up in the middle of
the night and you're gonna have to take
care of them
and and so the question you ask yourself
about before joining a startup is
are you prepared to do what it takes
because it comes with a lot of goodness
creativity
anything in life is there's no free
lunch
if you're getting the space to create
something you're also carrying a huge
responsibility
that you brought into this world aka
your child that you brought
in and you just got to ask yourself that
question
are you prepared to put in what it takes
to make a startup success
uh the long hours the responsibility
the the availability to take care of
things as and when they come up
and if it doesn't fit your lifestyle at
that moment in time or in
in your life journey you shouldn't do it
you would be disappointed you will get
frustrated the demands of a startup
are the demands of a startup you can't
expect a startup to give you a eight to
five
work environment and lots of you know
fancy parks
and and and fly in business class
that's not the model that's not the
model at all and i think i find a lot of
discontent in the valley right
silicon valley where a lot of people
join startup from
like google and other companies
expecting the startup to treat them like
they were in google
where you can work not work show up not
show up
do anything have frappuccinos in the
office and get paid two hundred thousand
dollars then
if a customer calls at six p.m he say
hey i'm off the clock etc
that doesn't work everybody gets
frustrated both the
company and you so you got to be very
clear about
in your life's journey are you ready
for a very serious responsibility
example being like having a child it's a
very serious responsibility
if you're not don't do it
so how will you help someone make a
decision whether they should find a
startup or not
so i think one of the most important
things to keep in mind is
to realize that there is no good answer
for everybody it is
a correct answer for me at this point in
time
for example let us say that
i have a parent who needs taking care of
and that requires me to have some
flexibility
that is the right decision for me just
because my batchmate has decided to join
a startup
doesn't mean that his or her answer is
the right answer for me
so to make this decision the first thing
that i would urge people to do is to
just be
first at peace with the fact that this
is not a race against anybody else
and when i say this i mean career
management
but rather it is finding the right
answer for yourself for example
my first boss spent 25 years at ibm
and then many more years after that at
microsoft
and i think from a financial perspective
he is likely better off than i am
despite my mucking around in a whole
bunch of startups and stuff because he
continued to make steady progress
he never saw a deep in his salary or
income and it was a nice linear curve
integrated across 30 years
it's it's a pretty compelling place so
more important than all of this
if we leave the financials out i think
the most important thing that i have
seen get in the way of people making
wrong decisions
is to try and be somebody else so
first optimize for yourself and then as
ram said all answers are good answers
and if you are able to and you can
always go back to a startup one of the
other things that has happened
even if that is an urge that somebody
wants to scratch
is people join startups at
all kinds of different ages so one other
thing to keep in mind by the way
is a high tolerance for uncertainty and
change
if somebody gets very flustered because
they don't know exactly what the next
year or six months or one week holds for
them
then don't go to a startup because in a
startup there is only one thing that is
guaranteed
which is that you really don't know what
is going to happen
and all the plans that you're making are
all highly tentative
so that is probably the other criteria i
was throwing along with what ram was
mentioning that you should have a high
tolerance for change
because everything is going to change
and i see a question pop up about age
any time is good to do a startup if
that's what you want to do
and start a startup and a great example
is dave duffield
who started work day when he was 65
years old
and a great example he's 65 year old he
starts his company work day
which has gone on as most of you know to
be
a very large successful company so
there's no age for that
it's an attitude and to ashish's point
it is a point in your journey when you
are comfortable taking it
you should take so i'm a very
interesting point in here i'll also give
an example of a
bangalore-based company so my neighbor
works in happiest mind he's the
senior vice president there and he's
talking about how his boss
mr suta was i think close to 80 years
he's taking his his
company public again and he's very very
excited he said he's 80 and he's very
excited that
he's taking the company public next
month so she's based on what you
said i have two one observation and a
and a question that i'll i'll start
the observation is that you said that
your boss worked in ibm and microsoft
for such a long time
and he is financially better off
so you are actually smashing all indian
entrepreneurs hope because the india
media
calls you the most successful angel
investor in the country
somebody was part of really really lot
of big story like flipkart and mockery
new sigma and i don't know how many more
just was smashing everyone's hope
to please treat that as i have never
asked him what his net worth is
and i'm also a poor money manager as far
as non-startups are concerned
so we'll treat this as a as a comical
interlude and we will move on to other
topics so i'll move on to the next topic
and i'll start with again
this time with you is that we talked
about is at what days you start in a
startup and
and so when we look at when you look at
hiring
in a startup so one of the trend that i
have seen is that when
when the startups higher or generally
the companies which are like still being
considered themselves as a startup which
might not fit into the definition that
you guys gave
they always look at is that has the
person worked in a smaller setup or
so-called startup or not
and when when the recruitment shows that
okay somebody has worked in ibm for 20
years and then they want to move to
startup
it becomes a strict no no and the
thought process is that for these guys
work in ibm he will be like very very
process driven he can't
gel into our culture he'll not be agile
and so on so
when someone is thinking and it might be
vice versa also maybe somebody's joining
an ibm i believe you have done
you've seen a scale that that that
doesn't even figure in our scale right
we are doing we are talk we always look
at thousand times the number that you
you are used to managing or seeing and
delivering
so now if someone is a young
professional today and they are thinking
about building their career
should they look at working only in a
smaller companies and have that kind of
experience on the resume
or they should look at a mix of may be
working for a couple of years in a
startup then maybe in a large
established company maybe then again
coming back
so they should look at this mix and
match what will be your advice and and
how do you see that resume versus
something which is like
only one kind of companies or a mix and
match how do you look at that
yeah so i think
while uh i did say that
one can go back it is harder to go back
to a big company uh and vice versa if
somebody has worked
for 20 years in ibm and then applies to
a startup
uh it is harder so uh i would probably
dilute my earlier statement
with this dose of reality that that it
is harder
in the technology industry especially in
the consumer tech industry
actually being older makes it harder
in any case uh forget about the fact
that one had experience
if one goes to an enterprise company the
dynamics will change
because the value of experience in
enterprise in certain states is higher
auburn goes to a consumer company for a
very special problem
let us say somebody wanted to build the
back end of a high performance system
then indeed experience is what matters
whereas if you're building the ui ux
for something then experiences is not
that interesting because you can do a b
testing
and come out with the right answer as
long as you iterate quickly
so module all of these nuances let's
let's come back to your question
i think for somebody to discover uh
what career path they want to take if
somebody has an answer then don't listen
to anybody else
because if you are in love then logic
doesn't matter
so this answer will apply to people who
are trying to
arrive at an answer logically as opposed
to emotionally
emotional answers always trump because
we find logical reasons to justify our
emotions
okay so we are talking about people who
truly are
saying okay what is the path i should
take if i am early in my career
i would actually try out uh i am given
enough latitude that people don't
consider me a job hopper
so i would try out two years in one
place not one year
because one year one day it takes just
to find the bathroom
i would spend two years to figure out
what
an experience means now to try out for
myself
as to what works for me because most of
us when we graduate from school don't
even know what is the meaning of a job
forget about being able to put all of
these concepts
into a framework so yes i would actually
try it out
may i add one point to ashish's point
yeah go ahead and in fact you can also
answer the entire question i also want
to add for the audience benefit that
maybe you are unique among all these
panelists that we have today that you
have seen ibm you have seen oracle
you have seen sap and you have been part
of so many high growth startups
so how do you look at and this you know
what you have
it's a good question so i for one have
crisscrossed between starting companies
and also running large companies so my
first startup was webmd
then i i went to work for a large
company peoplesoft
and that came back did another startup
called cast
system and and i've seen that happen
many people do it is that
i got asked the question what is the
difference between the startup
running a startup and running a public
company
and my answer was you know running a
startup is like flying a fighter plane
you you you have a very short runway you
take off very quickly
and you do a lot of damage in three
hours like you know you go at supersonic
speed and you get and and you damage it
to the enemy if that is
and but at the same time you can't be in
the air for 14 hours
a fighter pilot cannot be in there 14
hours three hours you're landing
running a larger company is flying a
commercial plane
it needs a longer runway it takes off
somewhat slowly you can't turn it on a
dime or do air flips if you may but you
can fly it for 17 hours
and go non-stop from san francisco to
auckland
now these both things have different
skill set required
so when you do a startup you're
exercising certain
kind of skill set or learning certain
kind of skill and when you run a large
company
you learn somewhat different type of
skills they are not the same
and and so the experiences as you grow
in your career
having done both sides of the equation
if you may
you round out your experience set
environment so to ashish's point
i think it's a good idea for young and
to be young people
to try a large company experience
and try a startup experience that first
of all helps you
uh figure out what you enjoy more but
also
shows you skills and and teaches the
skills
that are important in your future
journey
so so ram um just a follow-up question
to that so saying that uh
prospective startups will value both the
experience that's what you are saying
or you are saying that if you are a
specialist so you only so you've been a
fighter
pilot all your life and here is a very
important war
and we don't want to take a risk of
trying someone who has not done that and
who has not done
done it multiple times so do you think
the general will take a risk on that
fighter player pilot who has done it
multiple times consistently and
always gets it or someone who has who is
more experienced who has been a
commercial pilot also has been a fighter
pilot also
who do you think the general will select
in such a scenario i think that's a very
interesting and very smart question
so i think in a startup journey
there is a point in time when you need a
fighter pilot
and as you start to grow and you reach a
point now you need a commercial bike
so it is it is a matter of figuring out
at what
horses for the courses as we say at the
right
time you're gonna make a bet on the
right person or the right skill
but like we said earlier startups evolve
and they grow
and then they need bigger skill now
there's a skill to
manage a lot of entropy or uncertainty
but then you want to scale the company
you want to go from 10 million to 100
million dollars
at this time maybe you want the
commercial pilot to to take it from 10
to 100 million
but when you want to go from zero to
five maybe you want to fight a pilot
and if you have seen both sides of it
and you're capable of
morphing yourself then maybe you're a
better choice
versus somebody who you know after two
years with an auto capability
that this person is not going to be able
to go from 10 to 100 million dollar
has never seen it never understood it
and you have to change them
and that may not be a good outcome for
the journal as well
because now he knows that he can only
use this fighter pilot maybe for just
two years
then he had to bring a commercial flag
why not hire somebody you can go all the
way
yeah so i think that's an excellent
point and thank you for that so let's
move to the next point i think and i
also wanted to just
remind the audience as well as everyone
that we are talking uh
more from the perspective of a candidate
so that he can make the right choice
when it comes to his or her career
so next point that i want to talk about
is that
and i will again start with you this
time is that
if as a candidate if i have to select a
startup to work for
how do i make a decision like should i
look at the
or in general what are the important
things should i consider before i decide
whether i join
startup x or y or jet should i look at
the founder who's running the startup
is is he experienced or not has it done
done it in the past or not
should i look at if whether it is in a
hot technology area or not something
that i've heard is
there's a lot of a lot of like uh
demand or something that is going to
become big or should i just rely on my
friends that if they're working in such
a startup they're having a good time and
they're enjoying the journey i should
simply join them so if i have to look at
um
making this decision whether i should go
for referral or should i go on
technology should i go on honda's track
record or should i go on something else
that i am not thought about how would
you
advise someone to make a decision i
think that's a very very interesting
question
and a good question my view is that
you should join there there are degrees
of factor the
the fundamental factor is is the company
doing something
that appeals to me that is the most
important part that join
first decision metric for me is the
mission of the company is the company
creating something that appeals to your
heart and to like ashish's point
emotion always trumps intelligence and
are you emotionally aligned
with the with the mission of the company
that to me is the highest objective if
you're aligned with the mission of the
company
everything else will fall in place if
you're not
you may get you know your friends there
or the founder is a good guy
you still would not be satisfied because
the mission doesn't mean
much to you then it's just a job once
the mission is aligned that in the
second key factor then becomes the
founders
are the founders doing this uh
startup for a cause for a purpose for
changing something in this world
or they are there for a quick buck if
the founders are there
to make a quick exit out of it chances
are you'll be disappointed again
that's the second factor mission
alignment
and the founders why they're doing it if
those two things check out
in my mind the rest is just gravy just
noise
was really really helpful and i wanted
to point out one observation is that
when i talk to anyone in silicon valley
or
so that whatever any startup i think
most of the startups say that we are a
mission driven startup there are
startups who say that we are the mission
whereas i don't see that word being used
so often
in the indian ecosystem as much as as i
saw in uh
in uh well infidelity i'm had to meet
someone who says that who says that he's
not working in a mission driven startup
so
that is very interesting what will be
your picking order when you have to
advise someone to make a decision to
join a startup
or which one assuming there are multiple
options so i was actually in the same
place as ram
uh problem and people because
those are the two things that you have
to go back to every morning you have to
go back to
the problem and the people uh if you
don't like those
then who cares what will come five years
later if it ever comes
um so nothing nothing more to add
because i would end up complicating a
simple framework
so that's very helpful i'll again have a
follow-on question
related to the same topic of selecting
which startup to work for
so when we read about successful startup
like iconic ones who become like
global household names going forward and
if you look at the startups
journey as written by the founder or
somebody who has been very close to the
startup
one point that is pretty common across
all these startups is that
founders or the people who are running
the company talk a lot about culture
that
you have to define one one reason why we
became successful was culture
and it is across all kinds of startups
so what has been
experienced like we have seen so many
journeys whereas
both of you gave the answer you said
that the problem followed by the people
the culture didn't
uh figure that out so how do you look at
that point yeah so the people manifest
themselves as culture
so the if you were to model people
as nodes culture is the edges between
the nodes
because that is how they manifest
who they are and so the two are very uh
synonymous at one level
um so you know this word culture is a
very
interesting animal and there was uh the
founder of zappos
is a very interesting guy and he's also
written a book which
i read many long time ago i don't read
that many books unfortunately
but this is one of the few books that i
thought was an interesting one
so i don't remember the name but i'm
sure you all can find it more
efficiently he had given a talk once in
mysore
and that talk is stuck in my head
i think one of the elements of culture
which i find is
most important is the consistency of
what one says
so it is less important about what one
says it is more important
about whether one does what one says so
which is why often you find people say
oh amazon's culture is so different
oracle is so different than google is so
different than hp yet they were all
successful companies
i think what matters in culture is do
people do what they say
so you can definitely listen to what
they say
but then pay attention to are they
actually doing that
for example zappos had a reputation
of firing arrogant people one of the
elements of culture was we will not
tolerate arrogance
now the question is will you fire your
best programmer
if that person is arrogant if you don't
then it is very important to go and cut
that thing off your culture list
because it is not culture it is just
[ __ ] so
in my mind my i come down to just
one element of this culture which is
do people do what they say
because then i can deal with all the
rest of it
so actually that's a very good point and
for the audience i just want to call out
which book you're referring to
i mean the book name is called
delivering happiness and and i've also
read the book
indeed it's a great book uh written on
uh how we went about building the
concert
and i just hold on i think i have some
other important question that came back
from the response that you gave
so culture i think i agree uh to your
point that it's all about people
but still i think the same people in one
setup
behave differently compared to another
setup i will give an example see venture
for
funds in general are um are pretty
low on people count like they will have
at max maybe 20 people okay
and used to run still run
ventures and i see multiple startups who
came out of william
right from the lease years to i don't
know how many startups how many funds
came out of here
so what was different like what what did
you do differently
and there are similar story being told
by people right this people mafia has a
pretty popular word
on internet that they build multiple
billion dollar companies
so what was different so i think the
most important thing to keep in mind
here is that the venture fund is
relevant in the culture of the company
simply learns culture will be defined by
you
no offense meant not by ram not by me
why because uh you show up every morning
every evening every night
and we go back home and when the fire
burns you are the person who's running
around with the fire extinguisher
we wake up next morning and say ah
missed call from krishna
and then we will call you back okay so
the investors while they might like to
believe that we define things we at best
can influence things and even that is
many levels of interaction depending
upon
the person at the other end so i think
this
this particular question that you asked
krishna maybe there is a variant you had
in mind and i am
simplifying it too much
what the culture was of helion
or in helion would not end up
necessarily influencing the culture of
the companies that
culture would be determined by the
people who ran those companies
they defined those companies so i'm
coming back to you how do you look at
importance of culture and have you seen
setups where
the mission was big and the founder was
also was pretty
high quality but uh the company that
ended up being successful had a
different culture or or certain elements
of culture that made them successful or
all let's call let's ask the same
question in a different way
same problem statement same caliber of
team
two different culture which culture
really wins in the long term
or which culture increases the chances
of a startup becoming
more successful than other
okay i i my perception is on experience
actually
is that like ashish said
the culture is really the reflection of
the founders
and the people who are running it i i
don't
see that culture defines
of a company culture being put on the
board
as five different words whether
work hard and have lots of fun well what
does that even mean you're working hard
where is the time to have fun or vice
versa or soccer mode on
play hard play that that we have lots of
fun at the moment
like we work or we've had a lot of fun
and and so i i feel that uh kashish's
point is the company
is the problem statement
and the founders and the people inside
that company
that go to work every day defines the
success of the
it's it's the the culture is is a
manifestation of that and to ashish's
point
the same problem statement same founders
if they stick to what they say that is
whatever the culture is xyz doesn't
matter
if they maintain that xyz culture they
would succeed
often what you find is from companies
would have culture statements
but that's not what they're actually
doing inside the behavior is very
different from
the published culture statement on the
website or the internal website
and that is a recipe for failure
so you can choose any culture quite
frankly
that that that the founders invite and
reflect
and you can have a very successful art
or you can choose any culture
but not imbibe it and just keep it out
on the website in a very bad outcome
god so what i'm hearing both of you say
that any culture is good as long as you
stick free
it's not just a service you mean it and
practice it and people could feel that
right so if you don't try to just say
that i i
i become like that company wherein
you're just saying that but you're not
practicing that
and krishna so for example if you look
at oracle oracle is a much maligned
company for
some elements of quote unquote its
culture there are plenty of people who
are there for decades
so it will also depend upon what works
for
the person so it does come back to
not universal answer and therefore my
only request where i was going with that
is
would exhort people to not get to caught
up in value oriented
or judgment oriented statements not
value judgment oriented statements
that because often especially
with founders the external world
likes to pass judgment because that is
what we like to do in any case
especially with somebody who occupies a
position of prominence
it is very important that we should all
judge that person somehow we feel
compelled
so don't put too much talk into that
because the word arrogant
for example is often used to describe
people who are just honest
i would rather deal with a bluntly
honest person
than with a polite liar now if the first
person is called arrogant
then inshallah give me that arabic
person instead of this
polite snake now i'm insulting a snake
but uh so just keep that in mind that
please
go past the superficial judgments that
get passed on a lot of people
because we all feel obliged to judge
yeah i think perfect
so with that i'll just take us another
poll so stewart maybe you can run
another
poll on what does the audience think
that what it what it is
really like to work in a startup i think
there are a couple of options that we
had
we can run that poll and we'll see what
the audience has to say
and then we'll move on to some of the
interesting question that i see on the
chat window
and one of them is something that um i
think
i also come across when a lot of people
meet who want to be an entrepreneur and
they are considering ideas and they are
working somewhere they are not able to
make that
decision which is that i want to become
an entrepreneur
and i and should i directly go and start
working on my idea
or should i spend some time in some
startups and get
to see startups from a close quarter see
how they operate and behave
and then go ahead and become an
entrepreneur so what will be your advice
i should
start with you so
i think um there is
if this question is being asked the
answer is self-evident
to me there is a terrible movie with
robert de niro the movie is called ronin
okay don't watch the movie
but it has a dialogue which where he
says that when there is doubt there is
no doubt
now in this case
if a person is asking the question
should i go
start my company around this idea or
should i first go work in a company
at least to me it seems that therefore
you're not ready to start your idea
because when you're ready to start your
idea
people will be telling you that you
idiot don't do this
and you will tell them i am going to do
this because you don't understand
so when this question is being asked i
think the answer is
go work for somebody because you're not
ready not yet ready to start a company
so i think i should say i completely
agree with anything that you want to add
to that answer no i think it was
so beautifully stated i i just
wow that's so well said
yeah i i completely agree i think uh i
think that dialogue
is pretty good that when in doubt you
don't have any doubt it's
you don't need to ask anyone so that's
pretty well said so i think the
next audience question that i want to
take up with you is that
how important do you think is the
founder being from a technology
background like
let's say i am i'm an aspiring
entrepreneur and i have a problem
statement that i want to
attack and that problem can be solved
using technology today
any kind of problem that you think of i
think technology plays a big big role i
don't think you can solve without using
technology
but i myself know uh is not a technology
guy maybe a business guy operation guy
or whatever
how do you think uh what are the chances
of success uh for me as an entrepreneur
and how and more important how do you
think investors view that if some the
person is going and making investors
pitch
do you think investors are going to give
him a discount because the person is not
from a technology background uh
my experience has been that
in today's world and in fact since the
beginning of history of entrepreneurship
you don't have to be a technologist to
create
uh value to create companies to create
businesses
however you have to know what you don't
know
if you're not a technologist and you
pretend to be a technologist
that's a bad idea if you're not a
technologist
but you understand that you're going to
need technology to help solve this
problem
and you're going to surround yourself by
let's say a co-founder
who is deep into technology or some
other people in your company
who are deep in the technology you'll
have great success so you don't have to
be a technologist yourself
but you have to know what you don't know
don't pretend to become a technologist
overnight
just because it's tired company
somebody that maybe as you as we build
startup i think uh
there are filters like first you start
by maybe investing some money from your
own friends family then you go to an
angel and
then you go to a serious uh professional
investor and so on so we
think uh just a quick point there jeff
bezos was not a technologist
let's just talk about amazon it is the
largest company on the planet started by
a non-technical
perfect clearer man i don't want to keep
my example just after jeff
jones but i can't stop giving because i
became an entrepreneur because i hate
kodi
i'll make a i'll make a an observation
there though
both in your case and in jeff's case
you were both familiar with programming
and the point that i am going to make is
i think at least
right or wrong one that i have found has
hurt companies
if technology forms a crucial part of
the company
then either the founder should
appreciate
certain nuances of technology because it
wires the brain differently
a person who understands how
code and data works thinks differently
than a person who
does not so that appreciation
either should be present in the founder
or the founder should
have a co-founder with them who has an
appreciation
they don't need to be coders but they
need to understand the power of
software and i'm not doing a very good
job of saying this
it's like it's like knowing the taste of
something
no amount of description can help you
appreciate the taste of something till
you have tasted it
and one thinks of it very differently
okay so
this might not make any sense in which
case feel free to send me an email
later guys uh what i'm saying is that if
somebody brings the tools
of old fashioned three-tier distribution
to a technology-led e-commerce company
that person is going to get their ass
kicked
they need to think need to appreciate
that when you apply
data processing analytics fundamental
things change
in supply chains and so and so forth
which if they have to learn by getting
beaten up time and time again they will
never survive
so this is a good point and i think i
guess
when you look at hiring technology
talent i think um
there are different scale so let's say a
a series b kind of funded company which
is which is decent like
so they have proven their product market
fit they're already in the business
maybe their total team size is
say 200 300 number and maybe the
technology is 70 80 member
big when they hire technology talent in
their team they pay a certain amount of
money
now when you look at some of this
technology giant and let's take example
of
amazon again if amazon pays somebody at
the same
uh hire somebody at pretty much at the
same level maybe they'll pay 2x of that
amount or maybe sometime
x also so at the same level when they
are someone is hiring a technology
telling
a talent paying ex and somebody another
company is hiring and paying 2x
how do they judge what kind of qualities
do you think so if you have
to to let's say um stack rank
talent when it comes to technology and
product like somebody is really
building the the real stuff how do you
how do you
uh rate talent like how do you decide
this kind of people might fit into this
level of startup this kind of people
should fit into
a different kind of start startup
i'll pass this on to ram this is too
hard for me
right there is a startup which is more
like series will be funded so i'm just
qualifying that by saying that my
company might overall say 200 300 meter
people
like big already are doing decent
business and they're hiring a let's say
a c2 not
sorry krishna i understood your question
the problem is not in your articulation
i don't have a good answer to your
question okay
the reason i'll tell you the reason why
i'm asking this question i think
audiences came for me is that many times
when startups are hiring talent in their
team then
and there is a prospective uh
team member who is joining the startup
people always compare the
against saying oh i am getting paid x
but look at this by
this person who's doing the same job as
being amazon is getting 3x of me
now the natural question becomes that no
then you should go and work in that
company
there is a reason why they are paying 3x
and so that is a different question
sorry so the two the the second their
second variation of the question is
different than the first one that i
understood so that they're related
related in the sense that for some
reason they are not hiring
these people carrying a different kind
of people so how are they classifying
how
not only do i not know the answer my dog
has decided that i don't know the answer
so it's all yours so
krishna if i understand you right you
are saying
you're asking from the perspective of
the person who is hiring this employee
the house they decide or from the
perspective of the employee
which job he should take first clarify
that so surround from both the
perspective like
like for example when when people join a
company
and and they join at a certain pay scale
many times i see them
some kind of dissatisfaction saying oh i
am getting paid x
but look at my one of my college
classmate who's working in company why
and he's getting paid maybe 2x of what
i am getting paid but you seem to be
doing the same job
whereas i'm sure there are reasons right
see
10 20 30 percent variation is okay
because it's it's not a
there's no exact same i think i
understand you question that
so to your point then obviously there
are big variation
and for the similar looking job if you
may
you may get x dollars in a startup and
you may get
2x or 3x dollars in a larger company
and however uh when you
as a candidate or person trying to
decide between
the x what this 3x you have to again
ask yourself a question why do you want
to do a startup
if you expect a startup to pay you 3x
you're going to be disappointed you
shouldn't do it
you are joining a startup because you
want to help create something
you're joining a startup because you
enjoy working
in in some autonomous fashion you enjoy
the return on it
you enjoy the rush of or controlling
your own destiny
if you want to be a cog in a wheel and
get paid good money by all means you
should take the job
that is paying you 3x but then be very
cognizant
that you're not making decisions you are
be you are
now being told what to do and that's
what you will do
for the 3x money you're gonna make
you're gonna sell your soul
uh for that extra money that you just
took
and it's a personal choice you made and
it's
there's no judgment here in my mind
again if you are happy to be a cog in
the wheel and get paid more money for
that
by all means if you want to control your
own destiny
and and create something and get paid
less
in the beginning but as we also know
that the salary is just one part of
compensation
the equity that you get in startup is
likely to make more money
unlike the person ashish mentioned i
have done both public companies and
startups
i have made far more money doing
startups for my own self
and i've and i've been in real property
public company you get
got a lot of salary as compensation
but even then i made more money in in
doing startups
so financially it works out eventually
the salary might be lower
but the total compensation worked out uh
better
and i had more fun great point right
so now i ask another question related to
somewhat related to that or or somewhat
related to the entire topic
is that is there a right time to join a
startup like some of these
audience are asking that right now we
are
there's a pandemic going on throughout
the world there's a lot of uncertainty
should i join a startup at this point of
time
and i'm phrasing it by making it more
generally that is there a timing of
joining a startup
i think this is back to where ashish
mentioned the movie
if there is doubt there is no doubt
there is
always a good time to join a startup
there is never a bad time to join
starting
all crisis all economic financial
political crisis as you you've seen in
the past
are sources of opportunity only in the
time of crisis
innovation is born and they are saying
that saying don't let a crisis go waste
and there's a reason for that because
when there is a challenge
there are problems that need to be
solved that didn't exist before
so in my in and in fact if you look at
even venture funding
some of the best performing funds are
the funds that were started in the
downturn
the funds that were placed in 2001 or or
2008 to 2009
etc so in fact i have a contrarian view
of the world
which is now is the best time to join a
star
because this would give rise to so much
opportunity
i think uh around great pride that
reminds me of a story that we have read
during
childhood time right that leo tolstoy
story that says that who is the most
important person in your life right
and the answer is that you are the most
important person in the life
exactly i think i completely agree to
that now
even though this whole panel discussion
was about joining startups and and all
the questions that we took up was
related from
a prospective joiner's perspective but
since we have investors on panel i think
people
want to ask questions and i am just
taking that as a last question for the
day
so assist there is a question
specifically for you because there is
someone who is asking
you is that on what criteria you find a
startup and more important importantly
on what criteria
you reject your startup and i'm sure
there are there are multiple reasons so
it will go differently and help us
understand the top two or three reasons
which is a tick mark from you
and talked through two three reasons
that is a strict no no for you
um so it's a very hard question to
answer and
if there was a good answer to this my
failure rate would not be as high as it
is
so therefore please take this answer
with a very large bag of salt
um but given that the question has been
posed i can only duck
one question krishna had made that very
clear in the rules of the game
um so some of the things that uh
that i personally like um is
a company that is going after a problem
in a space that is new
um and that is because then more
mistakes can be forgiven
and it is also because i don't know any
space very deeply
so uh diligence becomes easier for me
so examples of new spaces for instance
in my older investments
mu sigma was done at a time where
analytics was
there were no outsourced analytics
players
so the opportunity was therefore that
you can make
daksha similarly there was only one
outsourced bpo player
which was spectrum but there was only
one
and the belief was there would be
hundreds so one i like new spaces
because then
good entrepreneurs who are smart
can make mistakes and those mistakes
don't necessarily kill them
the second question therefore follows is
entrepreneurs that i think are quote
unquote
people that i think will succeed and
what is that
in that among the few most important
characteristics in my mind one is
at the top is intellectual honesty and
intellectual honesty means the ability
to accept facts for what they are
as opposed to try and imagine a world as
you would like it to be
because if i can accept facts of what
they are then
maybe i have a chance of solving a
problem otherwise i don't even
appreciate the problem
outbound skills whether you have to
convince people to join you have to
convince investors to join you have to
convince customers to join
you need outbound skills um
the ability to think big but execute
small
you don't climb everest by just thinking
of everest you got to just keep
taking one step one step one step and
yet think of everest
so those are some of the things that i
find uh
are important in entrepreneurs some of
the things that are show stoppers in my
mind
um one of them turns out to be
if there are people who are
well they are converses of what i said
so i need to think of something
outside of what is not a converse
you know they all turn out to be i have
not thought of it as negatively
as what are the attributes i keep
thinking of things positively and the
reason
why i'm saying that is because at the
end of the day
the only decision i can make is whether
i am ready to join a journey
i have learned over time to not make a
decision on whether that journey is a
fruitless journey
because the number of times i have been
proven wrong is so large
that krishna i don't have a good answer
to your question as to
is there a marker for this is not a good
startup because
what the hell do i know so many
companies turned out to be fantastic
startups but it was just that i was not
ready to jump into them
so i don't have a good answer to your
question as to what our markers were
saying
no it's more looking for martha's to say
yes
so the fair point i think i also rate
somewhere by one of the very prominent
silicon valley uh venture funds saying
that
if they would have made investments in
companies that they pass
they would have made maybe 100 x more
return than income
by making investment in the companies
that they invested so i think
so i think for any prospective
entrepreneur is looking at
starting up if they if there are more
people saying no
there are chances that you will become
super successful so you should take
but take with a grain of salt okay by
that token we would start building a
perpetual motion machine
okay
yeah so now i'll um we are heading
almost towards the
end of this session i think i'll just
take one more question and then i have
just one
one last five side uh
chat but who have has only one question
so it's not a multiple
on the passenger last question before i
take up that is that um
is there any specific number of years of
experience that you
need to before you start a startups ram
what is what has been your
experience there like do you see people
straight out of colleges
because of course we have seen some
successes but where do you see the rule
of
thumb there so
i i the the anomalies proved the rule
right so there are some very successful
people as we know
who dropped out of college and started a
company and became very successful
however in my mind that isn't only
that's like saying
if you wanted to get strategy done would
you go to a
drop out of a medical school to get
strategy done on you
you probably won't do that you would
want to go to an experienced surgeon to
get operated upon
and the same is true for running a
business you must have certain amount of
experience
to run a business and so for me the
optimal
scenario is uh you've done
a few years of work you have understood
how technology works because like she
said you don't really learn much in
college when you come out of college
you don't know you don't even know
technology quite frankly forget about
business
so having seen one or two businesses
participating in them startups and see
what worked what were what didn't work
what
that made in the start of work you have
a general sense of it
and then when the when the lightning
strikes you
or the wave comes to you that says i
must do this now
and everybody might say no to you but
you got that feeling
you gotta do it you should go and do it
but you have
you have improved your chances slightly
by like like ashish also said that you
will make mistakes
you'll make a lot of mistakes but you've
improved the chances of
making some lessons record some of the
obvious ones you
have seen already uh before in your two
or three four years of
working experience in couple of starters
so my ideal time would be
spend two three four years doing two or
three start working at
two three startups and now you're ready
to do your own
i think very helpful ashley's what has
been your experience i think you also
started
first pretty much out of college right
or maybe you didn't really lost
this period of time i did two failed
jobs i worked for ibm for one year
had a wonderful boss missed that
opportunity worked for oracle for one
year
i had a wonderful boss and so it was
more my problem than the company's
problem but i indeed pretty much was out
of school when i started
i think a lot depends upon the space
so for example let us say you want to
start a security company
if you want to start a security company
chances are you don't know what the
problem is unless you have been in the
security space for a while
that might hold true for a number of
enterprise oriented products
if on the other hand you are starting
snapchat chances are if you worked for
too long you can never imagine snapchat
because you've become too jaded it
requires a certain element of madness
so now unfortunately there are no rules
so please treat these all as blind men
in the elephant
kind of exercise so this is one
perspective
to carry with you that it also depends
upon the space
then within the space it depends upon
being objective about what it takes to
so let us say that
i have a fantastic idea on security and
i'm just out of the school
but i believe that it is very very
compelling i should go compliment myself
with two three other people who have
deep knowledge of security
because it behooves me to figure out
that if i am going to go into a deep
specialized
space intuition is not the only thing
that i'm flying by
so if i'm making making sense in
addition to trusting oneself
also ask what is the so the maturity of
the space is one so
krishna to your point i became an
internet entrepreneur
in the online retail space
at a time where online retail was
basically starting out
so we made all kinds of stupid mistakes
i thought i was starting a database
company
it became an employment jobs classified
portal within the first three months
and then became a comparison shopping
site within the next 12 months
that can tell you how well we knew what
the hell we were doing
good news was because the space was
evolving and because the people who were
around the table were quick on their
feet
uh we evolved in line with where the
market was evolving
so uh i think just that is something to
i'm not sure if this made any sense but
i would
i don't have a i think all times are
good times
but depending upon the space the
relevant experience needed
needs to be either brought to the table
by the founders or complemented
relatively quickly so that they're not
smoking part
that's just great point i think when you
give this example of snapchat
the only thought that came in my mind
was that with all my
intellect if i have some i could never
imagine that why the hell somebody uses
tick-tock
okay
i'm i'm sure somebody who started knew
something that nobody ever thought that
there is something like this that
existed right so completely
there are areas that we don't know where
experience becomes so if anybody comes
to
with me to an idea like tick toys get
lost it's like such a stupid thing to do
why you are wasting your time
and you are giving something for
everyone else also to waste that time so
now we are at the end of the
webinar i think i have just i'll just
make one small line
and i request you to complete that
sentence and i think the last thing that
we are doing here on this
webinar is that if you have to complete
this sentence
don't join a startup if you dash dash
dash
what will be that association will start
with you
don't join a startup if you can't deal
with change
can't deal with change
don't join a startup if you want
a very structured environment to work
good so while the sentences are
different i'm hearing that the
meaning is same that if you can't deal
with the changes and i had to work very
hard to come up with different words
sorry
so i think i had a very good time
talking to both of you on this topic
very interesting and thank you for your
time and
thank you stuart for uh organizing this
i think i'm done with
whatever i had and maybe you can take it
over yeah
thank you thank you all very much um
and i would invite our audience to join
our next webinar
which will be one week from this evening
um beyond the textbook decision analytic
principles for data scientists
dr brad pauly is a lead technical
manager at salesforce and his
area of research is how
decision science affects data science
so again thank you all for being here
and you can get in touch with
simplylearn through our various
channels and i'm sure you can find our
panelists
through their social media channels as
well
this is the end of our webinar so please
do log off at this time
thanks thanks thank you thank you sarah
have a good day bye-bye
bye thank you everyone have a good night
bye-bye a good day depending upon where
you log in
bye
you